what's going on guys today we're
examining what it would be like if
saitama had a stand
having caught up with the one punch man
manga and webcomic
i finally have the data i need to craft
the stand
worthy of the cape to baldi but for
those who don't know what a stand is
let me explain stands are a power system
from jojo's bizarre adventure
that were first introduced in part three
of the series to put it very simply
they're a manifestation of a person's
life energy and each one has its own
unique powers
in saitama's case he wasn't born with a
stand but let's just say he gets one
after accidentally cutting himself
with this collectible he found at the
supermarket just before we get into it
be sure to sub to this channel as i'll
be doing weekly one punch man content as
of today
and i thought this would be a pretty fun
place to start i also have a
totally different anime crossover coming
next week so turn on notifications to
make sure
you don't miss it okay so the name of
this stand is sirius red which derives
from saitama's iconic red gloves
and his serious series of punches which
is when he decides to put in a
little bit more effort than usual just a
tiny bit
this is one of the few stands that is
completely sentient
and therefore it can think independently
and play video games
like its user red doesn't really
appreciate people with
excessively long backstories which ties
into its first ability
by emitting a pulse from the orb on its
head sirius red can alter a person's
thoughts and make it so the target's
backstory can never exceed
20 words to activate this power saitama
himself usually has to be in a state of
boredom
at which point his stand can choose to
trigger this pulse that covers a 10
meter radius
people affected by the pulse are
physically unable to exceed the 20 word
limit on their backstory
and this effect is known to last
permanently which makes this one of the
most fearsome stands
when it comes to people who just talk
too much the power does have one glaring
weakness though
and that's that the pulse can't be used
on people who declare themselves
to be saitama's disciple now seeing as
we're on the topic of its abilities
let's take a deeper dive into its
strengths weaknesses and its
other stand power that is literally out
of this world
as far as weaknesses go sirius red is a
close range stand which means
it can never stray more than two meters
away from saitama
even though it would much rather be
doing other things most of the time
because stands can often share physical
characteristics of its user
whether it be star platinum's epic
jawline or giorno's outfit which is you
know
mirrored quite prominently by gold
experience
inside thomas case red's second weakness
is that it suffers from permanent
baldness
something which it personally blames
saitama for on the flip side though
this done mira saitama in more positive
ways as well
specifically the fact that it has no
limiter
the strength of this stand is several
times that of king crimson
or star platinum or the world or any
other stand you can think of
and it's able to perform freakish feats
of strength
other close range stands typically need
projectiles to make long range attacks
but in serious red's case his punches
are so op
that they generate shock waves that can
be felt for miles
if this stand really wanted to get
serious a flurry of punches could do
even more than this
i'm talking about like wiping out entire
countries by all accounts it is a god
level threat i mean it could
destroy humanity if it chose to do so
this stand also has
incredible speed and perception which
changes the way it views reality
remember how in part five when
butcherarti's thought process
was just so accelerated that he kind of
like perceived the world in slow motion
this is basically how serious red sees
the world but just all the time
when combining this ability with his
super speed things like bullets
swords or any other kind of sneak attack
they can all be easily neutralized with
quick precision
for fans of micro academia vigilantes
you might also recognize that the
overclock quirk is another example
of a similar power to this moving on to
this stan's most fearsome ability though
if i was to compare it to the power of a
stand that already exists
then osiris or black sabbath would
probably be most appropriate
for reasons you're about to see the one
dimension punch is a special technique
that forcibly ejects the victim's soul
from their body
and then sends it to a crudely drawn
alternate dimension
souls transported to this alternate
dimension are reincarnated as
disproportionate and poorly drawn
versions of themselves
which can lead to some horrifying
outcomes we know that humans can turn
into monsters due to their
unsatisfied desires and their feelings
and
when someone's soul enters this new
dimension for the first time
there is a big risk of monsterification
think about it for a second
if you would turn from this to this
you'd understandably be confused and
distressed
and when you combine those feelings with
your desire to transform you know back
into your normal self
this will often trigger the
monsterification process
as a result sirius red's main ability is
the potential to monstify someone's soul
in another dimension the person's body
in the main timeline
it basically just remains lifeless and
will eventually die
unless the victim somehow manages to
return the primary way they can return
is because serious red it's a sentient
stand like i said
and so it sometimes does things that
saitama doesn't want and
on occasion it may do the one dimension
punch against saitama's wishes
this leads to him freaking out because
he thinks he'll be arrested for murder
i mean you can see why you'd think that
you know it's just him standing over a
lifeless body
and no one else can actually see his
stand so it does look a bit suspicious
on those occasions red can bring souls
back to this world
through a very short ritual that just
involves all the purple orbs on his body
to start
you know glowing the only other way for
a soul to return
is if it can beat the original saitama
in this
alternate dimension but so far that has
never been done
in terms of appearance sirius red is a
muscular humanoid stand
with built-in armor that is detachable
and it also has a heroic cape as well
his design was inspired by frieza from
dragon ball z
due to the fact that frieza was a
uniquely powerful mutant
even within his own species when sirius
red delivers a flurry of punches
it's stan cry is okay okay okay okay
okay which is uh
said in the same style as uh star
platinum's auras
he has similar robotic eyes to kakuwin's
hierophant green
and you know while these eyes are never
stated to have special abilities
i'm just gonna say that they can allow
him to zoom in on things that are miles
away because
why not but with that my friends we have
fully explained the glory of saitama
stand
let me know what you think in the
comments below and make sure you sub
for more one punch man content sometimes
i will also be doing jojo's bizarre
adventure videos
as well so keep an eye out for that
until the next one
peace out